morgan is directed by Luke Scott son of
Ridley Scott and tells the tale of an
artificial intelligence being named
Morgan that was created in a lab and the
group of scientists that are there
trying to make sure this being is raised
properly and when something goes wrong a
consultant played by kate mara is sent
to make sure things are all going the
way they should I don't want to say much
else about the plot because I actually
chose to not watch any trailers for this
movie in fact I didn't even know what it
was about when I bought the ticket for
this movie the person behind the counter
said I'm interested in this what's this
about man and I was like I actually
don't know a friend of mine had said the
trailer looked cool so I decided I was
just going to not watch anything and I
went to this movie completely blind I
didn't even know what genre this movie
was not making this up I had no idea
what I was going to watch so I was
pleasantly surprised to see the movie
unfold and I think that some people are
going to see this film and be very
disappointed because I went home and I
watched the trailer and the trailer
markets this has a very fast-paced dark
science-fiction action adventure
thriller eyed and it's really not like
that at all the first half of this movie
is deliberately slow-paced it takes a
while for the film to pick up so to
speak if you were going to this movie
expecting more of a thrill ride type
adventure it's not like that at all this
is a more cerebral movie at least for
its first half there's a lot of scenes
for the first half where kate mara is
just talking to the various characters
in this movie getting to know them
trying to figure out what life in this
small place is like and whether or not
this artificial creation is going to be
a danger to humanity or an advantage for
humans and so the first half of the
movie will bore people in fact I found
myself often checking my watch because
it just wasn't that interesting it's
well directed it looks nice it's well
shot and it's very well acted but the
issue for me with that first half were
the characters there wasn't really
anyone that I could latch onto they
weren't very interesting as people
everyone is given good performances and
everything looks really good and
everything sounds really good it's a
totally competent film in just about
every way the characters were just kind
of boring the second half however picked
up quite a bit with an interrogation
scene with an actor that I had no idea
was in this movie so I won't ruin
for you if you don't know either because
like I said had no idea what this movie
was about and everything after that
scene was actually kind of riveting and
I had a really good time with the rest
of the movie but some people will also
feel betrayed by that if you liked the
first half if you liked the fact that
the first half of Morgan was a more
cerebral film you might feel betrayed by
the last half being a little more
conventional action Hollywood type
entertainment that didn't bother me
because I had absolutely zero
expectations going in I was pleasantly
surprised by the good performances the
way the film looked the fun last half
and even though the first half was kind
of boring and the characters weren't
very interesting I did find myself oddly
drawn in by the movie despite the fact
that there have been a lot of other
films like this like ex machina or maybe
even species I guess this movie is fine
it could have been better the characters
could have been more drawn-out but the
action sequences were exciting I liked
kate mara quite a bit in this film I
liked pretty much all the performances
especially from the actress who plays
Morgan who was in the Witch and I'm
looking forward to seeing her work in M
night Shyamalan it's new movie split but
there's also going to be something that
I'm going to kind of maneuver as I
discuss it because I don't want to you
know ruin anything but there is a reveal
of sorts and I guessed it within the
first five minutes now that isn't
necessarily something I'm going to
detract from this movie because since I
guessed it so early on I decided to
watch the rest of the movie thinking
well if this is what's really happening
let's just watch the movie like that's
happening and I started watching the
movie like a hawk each scene and the
movie doesn't sheet and that's something
that I can definitely say is a plus for
this movie because it never cheats on
what you eventually figure out and even
though it was kind of predictable I
still like the way the film handled it I
think if you watch the trailer for this
movie and go into this movie with
expectations you will probably be
disappointed because it's really not
like the trailer the trailer gives away
far too much I'm not even going to show
any bits of the trailer in this review
like I normally would I'm just going to
avoid doing that because I think you
should go into this movie with as little
knowledge as possible just like I did
and I think you'll find the most
enjoyment out of it because if you go
into it with expectations you could feel
a little betrayed by this film and it
might affect your judgment in the end so
I think if you go in with as little
knowledge of the marketing as possible
you probably find the most enjoyment out
of Morgan not the best characterization
very good looking movie very great
sounding movie well acted it's just kind
of fine you know you watch it and it's
fine I'm gonna give Morgan a b-minus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward very soon to my
review of Book of Shadows Blair Witch -
I can't wait to talk about that I'm
reviewing called a Blair Witch movies
before the new one comes out I was
laughing because I I never thought I'd
say that I'm gonna review Book of
Shadows player which - okay you guys are
the best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
[Applause]